let's do a hard segue into one of the
biggest stories of the day we got this
from vox.com our favorite Lefty news
source Youtube CEO Susan would watch
siki is that he said I saw this piece
and I thought she's resigning by the way
I don't know how to pronounce this name
because I sure don't no because because
I've heard it pronounced so many
different ways people call her wojiski
but I'm like how is it wojiski it's just
Susan come on the show and tell us it's
time she thinks she's got an NDA but
she's resigning one of the most
prominent women in tech one of Google's
earliest employees is leaving the
company so I suppose the question is are
we happy about this or are we worried
about this I'm neutral about it you know
I I think this is you know it's the
devil you know versus the devil you
don't who's gonna replace her I think is
the biggest question because the next
person could be even more heavy on the
censorship ban